um let me ask you man i don't know if
you had a relationship with pop smoke
but obviously he's from new york that
was my boy
um great we got [ __ ] we didn't put up
great so you got some unreleased music
with smoke i think they leaked one but
i'm curious like his passing was so
tragic man
i just i talked to him the night before
he died you know what i'm saying like um
great kid man um like seeing that happen
obviously you being so close to nip and
having him passed away he passed
does that affect you at all being a
public person who obviously comes from
your background and be around certain
certain environments
do you do you like become a little bit
more
protective do you like even paranoid
might even be a ward like
like like is that something where you
like adjust the way you move
because [ __ ] man like it's you know
what's crazy about that
before and before that happened to him
on the my first album i
i dropped on dev jam's caller paranoia
yep and that's what that was if you go
watch them interviews that's what i was
talking about
the same [ __ ] that that you know
unfortunately happened
to them like but i've been felt like
that you know i mean it's just
that kind of make like scared me more
like damn you could be that lit you
could be that known
you know what i'm saying like in the
hollywood hills you could be that known
though like with everybody like you know
that's far away from home that far away
from anybody you probably got any
personal beef with
but it's all about how you moving you
know i mean that's one thing i'm
learning about life is like
you know some [ __ ] is just out of your
control but
you got to pay it once you become a
certain figure to the world you got to
pay attention to
every move is chess you know what i'm
saying like it's not
well i could just that you got to really
be oh no i can't move like that let me
send him to go do that
well i gotta meet let me stay here like
because you don't unders like
you don't know your effect on people
most of the time you're seeing people
they want to take pictures you
you're thinking it's love but you don't
know how a person really feeling about
you or what they would do to you
to get their name that's what jay said
if i shoot you i'm brainless if you
shoot me you're famous
yeah yeah i mean that's a fact like you
know what i mean so
i just um used both i was like i said
but right before that happened with pop
smoke
we was in the studio every day for maybe
six days yeah talk about y'all's
relationship i wasn't really aware that
you guys were like
he was locked in any time i'd be in
quality being he knew i was in the
building coming in
you come in the room you know i mean me
him in trouble did a record
trouble from atlanta um trouble me and
pop did like three four joints
last time we spoke oh it was all-star i
was in chicago i said you coming out
here
he was like now i'm about to go to l.a
whoa am i all right
when i get back to new york that should
happen but yeah i mean that kid was a
superstar even when you like just meet
him like what was something
something about about him that you kind
of took with you in the short amount of
time you guys knew each other he had
good energy
like he was he oh he like he really uh
was one of them people that like the
rumor you know what i'm saying when he
come in the building like everybody
don't got that
and it don't take jewelry it don't take
none of that like some people just got
that aura
well you know i'm saying like pop had
that you know i mean he had a good aura
around him
good vibe about him and you could just
tell he was excited
to be escaping poverty escaping the [ __ ]
we
we come from you know i'm saying you
could tell he was just excited to be
getting up out of that
so uh that that crushed me you know i'm
saying that hurt
yeah it was rough i was i'm i'm still
more than nip thinking about nip are you
ever damn saying and then that [ __ ]
happened
and then my boy my boy shooter died
right in this this past
may so i've been around these last two
three years been nasty
as far as people you know dying but i
just i take
each experience and uh try to
move or do something with it like
everything i got from nip and the time i
got to be around him fortunately
um i try to apply it to my life you know